when people are less focused on self and
the problems of the self there is a kind
of alleviation of stress there's nothing
like reaching out and contributing to
the lives of others to give a person
first of all a sense of significance and
purpose the idea of the helpers hi has
been around since the early 1990s
Alan Luke's a psychologist had
individuals going out and helping others
in various ways at low thresholds a
couple of hours of activity at a soup
kitchen or helping down the block or
whatever it might be and about half of
the individuals and this is a kind of
half-full half-empty paradigm reported a
feeling of elation a kind of emotional
buoyancy if you will 43% reported a
sense of warmth and tranquillity
certainly many of them reported a sense
of significance and meaning in life and
interestingly even 13 percent said that
they felt an alleviation of chronic
aches and pains now since then
scientists have been studying this care
and connection axis in human nature and
know that it involves certain hormones
like oxytocin oxytocin is related not
only to compassion but also to feelings
of tranquility or serenity if you will
and also to social trust there's a
wonderful study that Jorge mol mo ll
came out with several years ago down at
the NIH he had people coming off the
street just everyday folks and he gives
them a menu and on the menu you see a
list of charities that the subject could
consider contributing to it could be
your alma mater high school your
synagogue your church the alzheimers
association who knows and of course
they're hooked up to an fMRI device
which picks up activity in their brain
when they check a box next to the
particular line item that excites them
then the mesolimbic pathway gets active
and that's the deeply evolved part of
the brain the emotional part
the brain and it's the part of the brain
that is associated with feelings of joy
that dulls our feel-good chemicals like
dopamine for example and so we know and
I think this is perfectly Darwinian that
we actually do have a kind of
flourishing when we even think notice
this is a laboratory so people aren't
really shelling out their dollars but in
a laboratory environment when people
simply contemplate the idea of
contributing to others merely at a
financial level let alone face to face
there is this kind of a benefit